how does lore hunting work you guys ask
me stuff and we go and look at those
things so the character that i'm playing
on has every item in the game we can
read every item description we can i am
using this free cam mod to look at
characters closer like
i'm just kind of vibing with chat that's
how this works okay so the theory i
wanted to talk to you guys today about i
think might stir some real freaking
conversation man ah do i just wait to
make it into a video and then have you
guys discuss it there
i i really want to tell this but
i think it'll just make people mad all
right promise me you guys won't get mad
oh [ __ ] off the ledge
yes ma'am
oh well
oh this this is bad man
you guys gonna be like
huh
excuse me you guys ready for this he's
gonna wander around
there we go i have a theory that that is
not mikala
clear your mind and accept what i said
there
the only thing we're going off for him
to be mykola is because moog says
that
dearest mikala you must abide alone a
while or whatever
i don't know who this is
i don't know
but i don't think it's mikola and what i
think moog is talking to
is his blood
not the body form i think he's
whatever this person is in here
is a vessel
for mikala's blood
in whatever moog is trying to do so
he just refers to him as mikala because
it's full of nicolas blood and i do
think that mikala
is in the capital where we just were
which is what reminded me of this and i
have a theory
that
who i'm about to show you i think is i
think is mikla like this is a big one it
like can you guys imagine if i made a
video called this isn't mickela
with a thumbnail pointing to the to the
cocoon like people be like excuse me
no so what did you smoke
have you guys not noticed this thing up
here
i know if you look at the intro i don't
think
who's in the cocoon is mikala
i think this is mickela
or it's one of mykola's bodies
which goes into more of what i'm
theorizing is that mykola can take
many different types of bodies
it's close to the perfumer robes but not
quite it's not the perfumer tr i've been
i've been theorizing on this for like
two weeks now the item here is the
golden order principal which is how you
learn
that america is ratagon or ratagan is
america i think this is one of mykola's
bodies and he can do this because he's
been spreading his form throughout the
haley tree and now people are taking off
branches of him into it's really hard to
explain which is why i have not made a
video on this yet it's in
or near the bed's queen chain or yeah
the queen's bed chamber
this looks like a [ __ ] crib to me
hanging like why is this here like what
is this who is this it's just like this
hanging
it looks like a crib to me and it's near
america's bedroom it's right over here
right across the way it's america's
bedroom so if you guys look at the intro
um is there a way i can look that up let
me see
the cocoon's right here
it's on his back he's carrying it
it's dripping blood out of it
who is this
but i think a lot of people miss that
moog is carrying the cocoon here on his
back but
whoever this is is not inside of it and
okay so let look at this body right here
like we're all suggesting that this is
mykolo right look at the size here like
his like much smaller than mogu's right
much much much smaller than moog whoever
is in there is
much
much larger than moog look at that arm
that his arm is as tall as him i don't i
i i'm having a hard time believing that
this is mikala yeah it could potentially
be growing
this body here
very
very similar
uh body type to a um
to an omen okay so this body right here
boys
this is why we did this
why is it dark again
look at this body
in all of its glory
kind of cut out like a giant
i'm not going to cap on that i don't
know where that comes from
kind of gray
stoney
kinda sorta
eyes gouged out little spots on the head
things like that
and then
we go back over her
it it looks just like the body in the
cocoon
it is like
very closely identical to the one in the
cocoon
look right here
look do those those spots are exactly
the same
exactly the same
gouged out eyes spot on the forehead i'm
like right up in his crotch
ew like spotty
it is exactly the same but this is a
bigger model
is that a snake ring
fbi open up
i think this is an omen vessel
and we've seen you know like uh
morgot
can make many different versions
versions of himself all over like he
made himself a market
which
he technically dies there but that's
just like a
clone version of himself like kind of
like a summon of himself over there yes
the covetous serpent ring
this theory holds no water i don't know
how you can say that i really don't but
people will that's why i was saying like
you guys like even if you're like this
theory holds no ground you cannot deny
that mo or the body that's in this
cocoon whether it's mickel or not looks
exactly like the body of morgot when he
isn't a uh
when we kill him
dude his middle finger is a horn he's
flipping you guys off
mikala is the hailig tree
which i think everybody knows this right
everybody sees this face in the spite
right
maybe a lot of people have missed this
i think mikala is the haley tree his
blood is all within it and people are
taking out branches of it and putting it
inside of vessels
like the body we find in the cocoon and
trying to grow
a new empyrean demigod within this
[ __ ] cocoon
because i i'm pretty sure most people
see
like do you guys see the face
there's a body in the tree right there
which right here as well it would be the
perfect spot
for
like the tree is pregnant with something
right so this would be the stomach which
was the cocoon
which
i don't know if a ton of people have
noticed this either
but the cocoon is resting on a pelvic
bone
we just don't know that's what's so hard
about this we don't know for sure it's
like he's making almonds
using mikola's blood which is how i
think there are multiple
bodies what was melania doing melania is
blind he can't see he doesn't really
know what's there or not
she straight up doesn't have eyes
he's just such a skilled swordsman that
she can fight against us in that fight
that's what i'm thinking he took he took
mikala's like pelvic bone and is using
it to make a new imperium for his outer
god
where is she there she is like you guys
think she can see because i don't
she knows where she is
but she doesn't know
where mickel is he's at least not
answering her she's
so she just stays where was she when
moog took the egg the timeline on that
is confusing
because
it would make the most sense if she were
fighting radon
and then mogu just
press one in chat if we need dlc
better see a bunch of ones man we we
need dlc to answer these questions man
we really need more info we just don't
have it right now
we just don't
sucks
yeah a lot of ones my god so i think my
theory holds a lot of ground it will
just be very controversial
moog literally says that he's mickela
bro it's like maybe he's talking to the
blood
not the body
yeah the face is right here
nose mouth
eyes
it's definitely made out of like bark
treat
tree bark laura is all over the place
but damn i love this game
uh i mean i i said that in a previous
video where i think the lore in this
game is purposely purposefully
misleading
it constantly tries to throw you off
track with other things
and confuse you about absolutely
everything but that's just kind of how
it is
my plan for these streams is to kind of
do what we did today just kind of talk
with chat about everything and discuss
stuff i'm thinking about
editing them down into videos we'll see
how that turns out because i'm not sure
but appreciate everyone being here we
actually had a lot more people here than
i i thought we would so i really
appreciate that i hadn't streamed in
like a month so it was fun to come back
i always love streaming on youtube it's
been super fun so thank you everybody
for being here appreciate you very much
check the description for all kinds of
stuff that you might be interested in up
to you appreciate you guys have a great
rest of your day thanks for being here
and i'll see you all
again very soon